liftoff on the journey to immunity
at frankfurt airport heinz get pinkanel
and his wife katya
are setting off for an unusual type of
vacation
after months of searching for ways to
get vaccinated abroad
they're off to moscow a round-trip
package complete with a sputnik v
shot
we can't assume that we'll get
vaccinated anytime soon in germany to be
honest
but the more people that are vaccinated
the faster we'll achieve herd immunity
so if there's the option of getting
vaccinated in moscow then that just
makes sense
the norwegian travel operator is waiting
for the guests from germany on arrival
most of them have booked the kovid
package it includes a tourist visa
a stay in moscow and the vaccination all
for just under 2 000 euros
50 germans are taking part in the first
of these trips
and there's a lot of media hype
including from russian state tv
i feel like we're being stalked i'm a
lawyer and sometimes when a deal we work
on attracts a lot of media buzz this can
happen
but it's not quite at this level i'm not
political about this
i'm not a kremlin critic or a kremlin
supporter i'm fairly neutral
as long as i get my vaccine then that's
a great result
but russian authorities seem to have
their own goals in mind
the so-called all-russia people's front
a political organization headed by
president vladimir putin himself
has been providing visa support for the
tour operator world visitor
of course this is pr for russia but
what's the problem
sputnik v has become russia's calling
card around the world
even its name is a clear nod to soviet
victories during the space race
the vaccine has been approved in over 60
countries worldwide
that despite questions about early trial
data for the job
since the vaccine rollout kicked off in
december vladimir putin has been
personally promoting sputnik v
and presenting russia as a scientific
superpower
we've said from the start and now it's
been shown in practice as well the
russian vaccine is the best in the world
but people in russia are still skeptical
here the vaccination campaign has been
slow
coveted restrictions have been lifted
almost entirely
leaving little incentive for people to
get the job one
survey says nearly two-thirds plan to
steer clear
of sputnik v heinz get pinkane
doesn't share their doubts on the day of
his vaccination
politics is far from his mind i actually
have a needle phobia
sputnik v has yet to be approved in the
eu
but heinzkad pinkanel and his wife are
glad that they could afford to travel
for the job
it's a nice feeling to know that this
worked out and i honestly don't really
care if it's been approved in europe
for me it's simple i've been vaccinated
now and i feel safe
the studies so far i've shown it's
effective and now we're looking forward
to maybe being able to travel again in
the future
[Music]
now freshly vaccinated it's time for
some sightseeing
in russia the pandemic almost seems like
a far off memory
even if some experts warn a third covid
wave could already be underway
here in her home country katja harms is
enjoying freedoms she's been missing in
germany
i'm proud of my country and i feel great
here in russia
in germany i've lost this sense of
freedom of strolling calmly down the
street without a mask
you never know what's next
you can tell that the politicians and
decision makers are just floundering
helplessly
and that makes you feel helpless as well
yeah
and um and at the same time it also
forces you to take on personal
responsibility
and book a trip like this one for
instance
a controversial opinion perhaps but
according to the tourist agency hundreds
of germans have already booked their own
vaccination trips to moscow
sputnik v would almost be a luxury item
if it weren't so unpopular here at home
you